ان نغير البروتوكول الاصلي واليوم نعلن عن
اطار العمل الجديد اتفاق اليوم يقدم تجاره
مرنه مع المملكه المتحده ويحمي مكانه
ايرلندا الشماليه واتحادنا ويحمي سياده
شعب ايرلندا الشماليه لا هذه المفاوضات لم
تكن سهله البته لكن لابد ان اشيد بارسله
ورؤيتها في اقرار وجود طريق دائما نحو
الامام والى زملائي ايضا في وزاره
الخارجيه في ايرلندا الشماليه على تحملهم
وصمودهم المملكه المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي كان لهما اوجه خلاف في السابق
لكننا حلفاء وشركاء تجاريين واصدقاء وهي
مساله نراها وضوحا بصوره واضحه من خلال
دعمنا المشترك لاوكرانيا هذه بدايه فصل
جديد في علاقاتنا
على مر ربع قرن فان اتفاقيه بلف الصمدد
لانه في صميمها تحترم تطلعات
هويه كافه المجتمعات اتفاق اليوم سوف
يحافظ على هذا التوازن الدقيق وسوف يعمل
على رسم طرق جديده لشعب ايرلندا الشماليه
انني يقف اليوم لانني امامكم لانني اعتقد
باننا استطعنا ان نبدد الضبابيه والتحديات
التي تعترض شعبها ايرلندا الشماليه لقد
اخذنا ثلاثه خطوات نحو الامام الاولى ان
اتفاق اليوم يقدم تدفقا تجاريا سهل ثالثا
مع المملكه المتحده بحيث يمكن ان يتم نقل
البضائع عبر الخطوط الخضراء من الاتحاد
الاوروبي
وكانت في السابق هناك بعض عمليات
البيروقراطيه
المرتبطه بنقل البضائع وجلها تتعلق ببضائع
يوميه تستهلك في البقالات وغيرها بحيث
بات يتعذر على المواد الغذائيه المصنوعه
في المملكه المتحده ان يرسل مباشره اي
بمعنى بان هذه المواد الغذائيه باتت
تتواجد الان في كافه سوبر ماركت ايرلندا
الشماليه واتفق اليوم هذا يعني انه بات
بمقدور الناس ان يرسلوا طرودا لاصدقائهم
وافراد اسرهم دون ان يكون هناك اي اوراق
جمركيه ومعاملات معقده اي بمعنى باننا
ازلنا اي عقبه في ايصال هذه المواد ثانيا
لقد استطعنا حمايه مكانه الشماليه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي نحن نتذكر ان نصص الصحيح
في البروتوكول الذي يتحدث عن قدره
في كافه انحاء الاتحاد الاوروبي بما في
ذلك رسوم الكحول على سبيل المثال التي سوف
يتم العمل على تخفيضها
وهذا الامر ينطبق على نفس المنتجات
البريطانيه مثل الحبوب
والمواد النباتيه وغيرها
ومتطلبات السفر ايضا تمت ازالتها واتفاق
اليوم يقدم تسويه تاريخيه حول المواد
الطبيه فمن الان فان الادويه المعتمده من
قبل المشرعين البريطانيين سوف تكون موجوده
في كل صيدليه ومستشفى في ايرلندا الشماليه
ثالثا ان اتفاق اليوم يحمي السياده
الخاصه بشعبي ايرلندا الشماليه الاعراف
الاساسيه التي تنطبق في ايرلندا الشماليه
والاطار العام ترمي لتفادي اي وجود قيود
صعبه على الحدود بحيث يمكن استمرار الوصول
الى اسواق الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكنني اعلم
ان اناسا كثر في ايرلندا الشماليه يشعرون
بالقلق ازاء تغير محتويات ما يمتلون
يمتلكونه ويرونه في محلات ومتاجر المواد
الغذائيه
الكل كان قد صوت ليدلي برايه بشان هذه
القوانين الجدديه هذا يعني باننا نستطيع
ان نعمل على تامين كافه متطلبات المواطنين
في ايرندا الشماليه بهذه الطريقه
يمكن لاي جمعيه منتخبه ديمقراطيه بان تقوم
بتغيير اي قضيه
ذات
ديمقراطيه اذا ما كانت تؤثر على الشعب
والناس وفي وفي المملكه المتحده لا يوجد
فيتو لهذا الامر
الامر الذي بدوره يعطي ضوابط مبنيه على
موافقه الشعب اعتقد ان هذه قد تكون بدايه
تغيرا كبيرا للشعب في ايرلندا الشماليه
فهي تحل المشاكل التي يواجهونها وتعمل على
تحقيق التوازن لاتفاقيه
او اتفاق فرايدي في بلفاست المبرم عام 98
اتفاق اليوم هو اتفاق خطي وكتب بلغه
قانونيه وبلغه المعاهدات
لكن الامر يتعلق باكثر من هذا فحس بل اذ
انه يرتبط بالاستقرار في الرنده الشماليه
والشعوب الحقيقيه
وممارسات الاعمال التجاريه ويتعلق بان
يظهر بان اتحادنا استمر لقرون وبمقدوره
الصمود ويتعلق ايضا بازاله كافه
العقبات امامنا وان نعمل على تنحيه كافه
الخلافات التي لطالما فرقتنا وان نعمل على
المشاعر التي تجمعنا هذه الاسره اسره
الامم
التي تعد متحده في المملكه المتحده شكرا
اسعد الله اوقاتكم شكرا رئيس الوزراء رئيس
الوزراء الريشي انه لشرف
ومن دواعي سرور ان اكون معكم هنا وانه
لدرجه من الرضا ان نقف سويه هنا فاننا على
وشك
ان نقدم التزاما كبير كنا قد بداناه منذ
بضعه اشهر او تذكروا اول مناقشه لنا عندما
كنا قد
اجتمعنا حول كيفيه دعم القوات الاوكرانيه
سابقا ولطالما تشجعت
بالدعم الكبير في ظل هذا
كيف
عملنا سويه حول الصعوبات التي كانت تعترض
علاقاتنا المشتركه وكان من الضروري بمكان
ان نضع الامور في نصابها الصحيح اذا
التزمنا بان نعمل بجد سويا
وكنا نعلم انه بالنسبه لنا وحتى يتسنى لنا
الاستغلال الامثل لقدراتنا واستنباط
الحلول
والعمل بموجب بروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه
نعلم بان الامر لم يكن سهلا بهذه الدرجه
وانه كان لابد لنا ان نستمع لمخاوف بعضنا
البعض بدقه والاهم من ذلك ان نستمع الى
مخاوف الشعب في ايرلندا الشماليه
نعلم بانه كان يتوجب علينا ان نعمل بعقول
منفتحه وعزيمه ولكننا ندرك ايضا اننا انا
وريشي بمقدورنا تحقيق ذلك لاننا
ملتزمان بصوره عامه لايجاد حل عملي للشعب
ولكافه المجتمعات في ايرلندا الشماليه
اليوم
يمكننا ان نشعر بالفخر
والاعتزاز لاننا قدمنا لاننا اوفينا بهذه
الالتزامات لاننا توصلنا الى اتفاقيه من
حيث المبدا
يمكننا من خلالها ان نشعر بالثقه وكذلك
الحال بالنسبه لشركات التجاريه هذه الحلول
المستنبطه التي تتصدى لكافه المحاور في
تلك الشركات التجاريه
رئيس الوزراء كان قد عمل بصوره جده في
جمله من المجالات الترتيبات الجديده تقدم
رزمه متكامله بحيث يمكننا من خلالها ان
نتطرق بطريقه حاسمه لكافه شان يرتبط بحياه
الناس بصوره يوميه ودعوني اضرب مثالين فقط
حول اطار
بحيث يتم التاكيد بان نفس المواد الغذائيه
الموجوده في المملكه المتحده سوف تكون
متواجده في ايرلندا الشماليه كما هو الحال
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا الاطار ايضا سوف
يمكن كافه الادويه
والمواد الطبيه التي تكون موجوده في
ايرلندا الشماليه في ذات الوقت وفي ذات
وفي ذات الشروط والاحكام الموجوده بها في
المملكه المتحده
لانجاح هذا الامر اتفقنا على روابط
وضمانات مثل قدره وصولي
تكنولوجيا المعلومات بما يحمي نزاهه
السوق الموحد في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
اتفاقي ونشر سوف يعمل على حمايه اسواقنا
وشرعيه
ومصالحنا المشروعه وكذلك سوف يعمل على
حمايه مكاسبنا الشرعيه بشان اتفاق بالفسد
وبالنسبه للشعب ايضا في ايرلندا في
ايرلندا الشماليه لا يوجد للعنف اي مكانه
في مجتمعتنا وانني ادين من صميم قلبه
عمليه اطلاق
ضابطا في ايرلندا الشماليه في الاسبوع
الماضي
وافكارنا وصلواتنا مع اسرته
هذه السنه
تشكل الذكرى السنويه الثانيه والعشرين
لاتفاق بالفاست وعمليه السلام التي طوت
ثلاثه عقود من الصراع هذا الاتفاق سوف
يعود بالنفع على ايرندا الشماليه ويدعم
كافه المجتمعات ويتم من خلاله الاحتفائي
بالسلم في ايرلندا الشماليه ولهذا استطيع
ان اقول انه بمقدورنا ان نفتح صفحه جديده
في علاقاتنا ان علاقات قويه بين المملكه
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي يجعلنا شركاء
اكثر قوه الان وفي المستقبل شكرا جزيلا
لدينا بعض الاسئله التي يمكن طرحها فلنبدا
من بي بي سي شكرا
اذا كان الحزب الوحدوي الديمقراطي في
ايرلندا الشماليه لا يوافقوا على هذا
الاطار ما الذي يمكن فعله نعلم ان كما
تعلمون ان هذا اليوم يعد نقطه تاريخيه في
الرنده الشماليه فتره للاستماع
لنقابات واناس الذين عبروا عن مخاوفهم
وارى ان اطار عمل اليوم يتطرق الى تلك
المخاوف بحيث يمكن من خلاله ان يتم حمايه
مكانه ايرلندا الشماليه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ويحمي نزاهه الشعب في ايرندا
الشماليه وفي ذات الوقت ادركه ان الاحزاب
والمجتمعات قد يحتاجون لوقت
لاستيعاب التفاصيل التي خذناها اليوم وسوف
نعطيهم حريه الوقت